[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous et le retour de
parlement hebdo 13 heureuse de vous
retrouver après quelques mois de
suspension des travaux parlementaires et
on reprend avec katia gilbert sur les
chapeaux de roue après l'élection de la
nouvelle assemblée notre premier invité
pour cette 16e législature qui commence
et bien c'est violette spillebout de
bonjour bonjour vous êtes député
renaissance du nord et c'est katia qui
va vous présenter bonjour tam bonjour
violette et en jours de 8 députés la
tout nouvelle députée du nord nouveau
visage de l'assemblée nationale mais pas
novice en politique
si je me trompe pas puisque vous êtes
militante vous avez été militant
socialiste à la fin des années 90 vous
avez rejoint martine aubry vous allaitez
sa directrice de cabinet et puis après
plus de dix ans passés un peu dans
l'ombre de la maire de lille vous partez
vous décrocher un poste à la sncf en
2013 aux ressources humaines vous est
notamment chargée des situations
sensibles et puis parallèlement vous
remettez le pied en politique candidate
à la mairie de lille en 2020 vous
finissez troisième derrière martine
aubry et le candidat écologiste et puis
deux ans plus tard et bien vous êtes là
vous entrer à l'assemblée j'ai envie de
vous poser une question quand vous voyez
la tâche difficile qui s'annonce pour
les nouveaux et nouveaux venus notamment
qui font partie de la majorité
renaissance est ce que ça ne vous
effraie pas
ça ne m'effraie pas mais c'est
impressionnant parce que on voit
l'assemblée les débats sur votre chaîne
notamment quand on est citoyen quand on
est élu local et on voit le sérieux en
fait de l'ensemble des travaux
parlementaires et de la nécessité de
servir le pays et de faire sortir
rapidement des lois mais quand on arrive
comme moi nouvelle députée ce qui est
très impressionnant c'est dans le climat
où nous sommes actuellement le sentiment
de responsabilité ça fait une première
émotion on arrive dans ce bâtiment
patrimonial du palais bourbon le symbole
de la république française donc une
émotion forte et puis très rapidement on
est haut sur les sujets de travail moi
je suis depuis quelques jours en train
de m'organiser
je dois recruter des collaborateurs
gérer la partie administrative du
transfert de mon contrat de tracer sa
route et vous arrivez à je dirais que
c'est un petit marathon comme l'était la
campagne on ne s'est pas arrêté je me
suis pas à reposer pour l'instant je
pense que ce sera plutôt pour le mois
d'août vu comment on est parti mais en
même temps on est là pour ça voilà
est-ce que vous auriez souhaité ou
est-ce que vous souhaiteriez une
nouvelle formation pour les nouveaux
arrivés en puisque katia l'a dit bien
vous venez là du monde de la sncf plutôt
donc un tout autre métier mais on est
déjà très très bien accueilli je trouve
que alors moi je suis arrivé lundi matin
assez tôt j'ai été accueilli par aurore
bergé qui maintenant ne présidente de
groupe que je connaissais
immédiatement dans les couloirs on a
finalement une transmission de pair à
pair hier j'ai encore reçu les messages
de certains députés qui me proposent
leur aide pour comprendre le
fonctionnement d'une commission et puis
on a les fonctionnaires de l'assemblée
nationale qui au delà de l'accueil
chaleureux qu'ils nous réservent en tant
que nouveau sont vraiment à notre
disposition que ce soit sur le plan des
outils sur le plan d'eau du mécanisme
législatives on se rappelle exams en
2017 tout le débat sur les amateurs
est-ce que vous pensez que vous en êtes
encore là au niveau de votre formation
ou quand même ça a changé au bout du
bout de cinq ans il ya 5 ans
d'expérience et là on le sent d'abord
parce que quand je me suis retrouvé dans
la réunion de groupe mercredi matin j'ai
retrouvé des personnes que je
connaissais pas ce que nous avions
travaillé ensemble sur les élections
municipales dans nos villes ou sur les
élections régionales ou départementales
des personnes qui sont expérimentés qui
connaissent déjà la beauté du jeu qui
vous a beaucoup d'élus locaux beaucoup
de personnes qui ont déjà été candidat
beaucoup de personnes qui parfois
servait l'intérêt général et le service
public dans d'autres fonctions et qui se
sont lancés aux législatives on a encore
quelques personnes qui viennent vraiment
de la société civile j'ai rencontré un
avocat hier ou avant-hier mais on sent
qu'il ya à la fois une mixité de profil
est d'origine est à la fois un
professionnalisme et des compétences
dont nous aurons grandement besoin dans
les défis qui arrive on va en parler
mais on va d'abord déroulée les 3 thèmes
de cette émission après le choc
électoral de dimanche
l'assemblée a redémarré avec l'entrée en
force de nouveaux visages politique et
un bataillon macro nice réduit on
reverra les images de cette rentrée
parlementaire inédite emmanuel macron
reconnaît la fracture des législatives
et renvoie aux oppositions la
responsabilité de sortir de l'impasse
les oppositions renvoie la balle au
président de la république leur réaction
dans cette émission et puis les
sénateurs présentent une proposition de
loi pour encadrer le recours au cabinet
de conseil par les pouvoirs publics un
texte déposé trois mois après les
conclusions fracassante de la commission
denquête
les nouveaux députés ont donc fait leur
rentrée à l'assemblée les élus de
l'alliance de gauche suivie le lendemain
par ceux du rassemblement national
autour de marine le pen deux images de
style différent on revoit toutes ces
images avec marco pommier
ambiance détendue mardi matin place du
palais bourbon la nuque fait son entrée
à l'assemblée photo de famille pour les
insoumis écologistes socialistes et
communistes
objectif affiché l'unité de la coalition
les 76 insoumis foule les marches du
palais bourbon avec jean luc mélenchon
désormais ex-député il s'improvise
professeur comme un passage de témoin
à
changer la décoration est le fondement
est biblique sur un
autre ambiance mercredi 89 députés
rassemblement national entre dans
l'hémicycle de l'assemblée jamais il
n'avait été aussi nombreux sur le perron
du palais bourbon les élus applaudissent
marine le pen
et pour la première fois depuis 1986 le
rn va former un groupe parlementaire
tout ce qui va dans le sens de l'intérêt
de la france et des français nous le
voterons tout ce qui nous apparaît
perfectible nous la mènerons est tout ce
qui nous apparaît toxiques ou néfaste eh
bien nous y opposerons rentrée sans
euphorie en revanche pour le groupe
renaissance à de majorité absolue pour
emmanuel macron qui peut compter à ce
stade sur 250 députés aurore bergé
devient la première femme à diriger un
groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée mais à
chaque fois on dit que ça il ya des
pires passe dans la démocratie mais ça
dépend ce qu'on souhaite parce que son
épouse qui sont exigeants qui sont
essentiels et qui permettent encore une
fois d'avoir une majorité de pouvoir
tenir ensemble autres présidents de
groupe celui des républicains
olivier marleix qs la droite affiche sa
volonté de concilier opposition et
esprit de responsabilité
de profiter de la situation la
configuration étonnante de l'assemblée
soit un groupe d'opposition qui
défendent se bat pour obtenir des
avancées pour les français mardi la
législature s'ouvrira par l'élection à
la présidence de l'assemblée nationale
à la fête fil boule on a reproché à vos
collègues été élu en 2010 est d'être un
peu une majorité playmobil de voter aux
ordres alors que et bien finalement un
député il est libre de son vote vous
vous serez quel style de députés est ce
que vous allez être un peu dans cette
majorité playmobil ou vous serez même
jusqu'à être affranchis je crois déjà
que l'élection d'horreur berger qui a
gagné largement au premier tour cette
élection interne à notre groupe
renaissance qui est une femme jeune qui
incarne la nouvelle ligne la nouvelle
méthode
de notre groupe renaissance est un signe
extrêmement positif sur la façon dont
nous allons exercer notre notre mandat
moi je me définirais comme une députée
authentique j'ai bien la dcri
avec en tout cas une franchise dans
l'analyse avec avec une capacité à être
à la fois loyal à notre groupe parce que
je pense que c'est important on est dans
un moment extrêmement stratégique
historique pour notre pays il nous faut
au sein de notre majorité présidentielle
une unité donc de la loyauté mais aussi
une liberté d'expression et de débat au
sein de notre groupe et avec nos
partenaires de la majorité
présidentielle horizon modem donc je
crois qu'il faut être comme on est c'est
à dire il va falloir être dit sabrina
hémond de discipline et au niveau des
votes quand on a une majorité relative
c'est pas forcément le moment où on peut
le plus s'exprimer par des votes
différentes son groupe sarr
effectivement on a on a quelque chose
qui nous rassemble et qui est très fort
c'est le projet d' emmanuel macron qui
va être la base des négociations avec
les partenaires des groupes d'opposition
qui vont s'associer à nous soit de façon
durable ou souhaitent façon plus courte
on y reviendra mais en tout cas il ya
quelque chose qui nous rassemble et qui
ne va pas être difficile pour nous
puisque on a tous les uns les autres
pour l'élection présidentielle emmanuel
macron puis pour les législatifs porter
un seul et même projet qui celui d'
emmanuel macron pour la france le
pouvoir d'achat la santé l'éducation la
transition écologique avec une
accélération de ces sujets là donc moi
je suis très confiante sur la qualité
nos débats et puis aurore bergé sur un
moment donné avec beaucoup de
responsabilités derrière un autre poste
très stratégique ces oublis de la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale yaël
brand piv et votre collègue a été
désigné par là et lui-même par par la
majorité est ce que c'est le bon profil
pour gouverner si je puis dire une
assemblée qui s'annonce ingouvernable
d'abord elle a été élu au deuxième tour
avec une belle à la majorite' majorité
au sénat semble et sociales dont
d'émancipation qu'il ya lebron pub etc a
en tout cas c'est le choix des députés
vous parler de liberté c'est ce qu'on
disait verdon pour expliquer notamment
nathan deakes ronan lescure était plutôt
le candidat du palais de l'elysée
emmanuel macron qu'il ya une brawn pie v
donc et plutôt la candidate des députés
ça c'est un signe quand même
d'émancipation du groupe de vote en tout
cas c'est un signe d' authenticité c'est
à dire que moi je vais être clair avec
vous je connais peu il ya une brebis
vais je la connais plus médiatiquement
elle a été élue à la majorité elle est
légitime pour moi et nous serons tous
derrière elle pour porter sa candidature
à la présidence de l'assemblée nationale
c'est une femme brillante extrêmement
engagé qui a été présidente de
commission qui a les reins solides pour
exercer ce rôle ensuite à titre plus
personnel j'étais très ami avec avec
roland lescure je le suis encore parce
qu'on était au bureau national de la
république en marche ensemble qui m'a
beaucoup aidé pour les municipales donc
c'était aussi un très bon candidat
aujourd'hui il ya un choix de la
nouveauté de la nouvelle ligne qui est
incarné par ryan braun pie v et aurore
bergé moi je suis très heureuse qu'elles
soient ses fonctions stratégiques et je
suis sûr j'espère qu'elle sera yaël
président de l'assemblée nationale dans
ce poste extrêmement important autres
prochain alors autres postes très
importants la présidence de la
commission des finances qui a des
pouvoirs à tout puissant la règle des
institutions c'est qu'elle revienne au
premier groupe d'opposition là on sait
pas trop est ce que c'est le
rassemblement national ou alors est-ce
que c'est la nuque pour vous est-ce que
ce serait un problème que cela revienne
par exemple rassemblement national ce
poste pour moi c'est un problème et une
tristesse qui a un groupe de d'élus
rassemblement national aussi important à
notre assemblée mais je le respecte
c'est le choix des électeurs on a une
assemblée plurielle avec des députés qui
représente l'extrême gauche et l'extrême
droite mais là dessus ils sont légitimes
ils ont été élus donc on va devoir
dialoguer pas en faire des partenaires
ça c'est bien sûr mais dialoguer ensuite
sur la question de la présidence de la
commission il ya un débat sur qui est
vraiment la plus résistants
l'assemblée vote la nuque déjà vavin son
candidat la main on voit comment la
nuque sva va évoluer en tout cas ce qui
est sûr et la première ministre l'a dit
s est clairement hier c'est que nous ne
prendrons pas part au vote nous
respecterons le choix des oppositions je
crois que là aussi on a un nom de la
règle difficile et donc on a un moment
où il faut être responsable et
respectueux du choix des français et de
l'organisation des institutions et pas
commencer à faire des déclarations dans
tous les sens lorsque gérard larcher dit
que cette présidence devrait revenir au
rassemblement national est ce que pour
vous c'est une glissade irresponsable
comme certains l'ont dit ou est ce qu'il
ne fait que rappeler les règles des
institutions c'est son analyse il ya une
question assez juridique si je comprends
bien moi et en venant d'arriver sur la
légitimité d'un groupe ou d'un autre
donc là il ya un sujet sur la nuque avec
effectivement l'entente
commencent à se désolidariser puis qui
reviennent pour les histoires de postes
tout ça ça fait un peu tambouille je
crois bien que ça intéresse beaucoup les
électeurs moi je pense qu'il faut que le
vote se passe bien et que nous
respections le nouveau ou la nouvelle
présidente de l'agrégation savalas sur
vous devrez vous resterez là dessus
alors emmanuel macron est sorti mercredi
de son silence à 20 heures après ses
rendez vous avec les différents chefs de
l'opposition il a appelé à élargir la
majorité pour tenter de sortir de
l'impasse écoutez ces réactions après la
location du président de la république
l'allocution du président recueillis par
marion becker et sandra sert qu'à eux de
savoir s'ils respectent leurs positions
et s'ils sont prêts à faire des
concessions à prendre en considération
les demandes que nous portons et qui
sont celles finalement souhaité par des
millions de français mais dès qu'il
s'agira de pouvoir réfléchir un euro
dans la poche des français nous le
ferons mais nous demanderons à l'est
surtout beaucoup plus loin nous
maintenant
fait du pied mais fait du pied c'est
bien et la cape comme monsieur mélenchon
premier ministre pour qu'on puisse enfin
avoir un gouvernement avec des gens de
gauche au pouvoir pour qu'on puisse
aider le peuple parce que l'urgence
sociale c'est maintenant il faut arrêter
de croire que les institutions vont
pouvoir changer des choses dans 35 50
ans sur le président venait expliquer
votre projet pour la france et venait
expliquer devant non pas une caméra de
télévision de manière descendante sans
contradiction mais devant le congrès de
versailles dans le cadre de l'article 18
de la constitution
en réalité le président république
annoncé qu' on allait atteindre les
blocages et qui aurait une dissolution
l'événement politique ça aurait été de
dire j'ai été désavoué dans les urnes
par les français aux élections
législatives et à partir de là je
m'engage à modifier un certain nombre de
lignes politiques de ce que je réalise
pour tenir compte des aspirations des
colères des souhaits des uns des autres
ils boudent sans majorité absolue vous
devez trouver des alliés pour faire
appliquer le programme d' emmanuel
macron ses alliés ou les trouvez-vous
bien chez tous les députés qu'il soit en
groupe ou isolées qui partagent au
minimum on va dire nos valeurs
républicaines même si on n'est pas
alignée sur de la musique est politique
au delà des étiquettes politiques
d'abord il ya des personnes qui qui
déjà font dessinent aujourd'hui je pense
à isabelle ardon christelle morancé la
présidente ait l'air de la région qui a
qui s'étreignent clairement expliqué
exprimé à renaud muselier à d'autres
élus qui donc c'est plutôt du côté des
l'air plutôt de ce côté là montre en
tout quelque ils sont prêts à une
coalition on a des divers gauche aussi
avec lesquels nous discutons donc au
delà bien sûr des étiquettes sans
compter des discussions que nous
n'aurons pas avec le rassemblement
national c'est clair je le redis ici ou
avec des élus de l efi en tout cas dans
l'espace central de l'assemblée
nationale nous souhaitons et la première
ministre l'a très bien expliqué aller
vers une coalition ce qui serait le
format qui permettrait d'avoir une
majorité absolue est de faire beaucoup
plus vite avant ces lieux et notamment
pour sa part est bien évident par
rapport à nos traditions institutionnels
et en même coalition voyez on a vu
clément boon qui s'exprime et tous ceux
qui connaissent bien le fonctionnement
des autres pays européens c'est très
classique dans d'autres pays européens
et la commission pas en france il faut
qu'on s'adapte c'est une nouvelle ère
emmanuel macron l'a très bien dit c'est
une nouvelle ère démocratique ça montre
aussi que l'assemblée nationale devient
le coeur battant de notre démocratie
notre dialogue donc ça va être
passionnant pour nous qui sommes
nouveaux députés on va devoir notre cap
montrer notre capacité à comprendre les
français a montré qu'on les a entendus
quelle que soit leur vote parce qu'on
représente tous les français et a montré
qu' on est capable de discuter de faire
un pas vers l'autre dans un sens et dans
l'autre c'est à dire que oui il y aura
des concessions sur mes dents grincer
des dents manuelles magnum bien sûr et
mary elizabeth bourdin vous venez de
parler à l'instant et qui n'a d'ailleurs
pas été cité lors de l'allocution des
manières macro pour vous doit-elle se
soumettre à un vote de confiance à
l'issue de son discours de politique
générale alors moi je partage pas du
tout cette analyse d'abord parce que si
emmanuel macron n'a pas cité la première
ministre c'est parce qu'il était dans
son rôle de chef d'institution et qu'il
parlait aux françaises et aux français
sur la stabilité de notre pays donc il
n'a pas parlé du gouvernement ni de
tambouille de poste ou de personnes mais
il est resté sur l'objectif général qui
est assuré la stabilité dans notre pays
au regard de tout ce qui se passe autour
de nous et
de l'inflation par exemple et de tous
les sujets qui touchent les français
alors forêt sur elisabeth bornes moi je
soutiens complètement elisabeth bornes
dans ce qu'elle a fait et ce qu'elle
fait aujourd'hui d'abord parce que c'est
une femme politique moi je tiens à leur
dire moi je suis une femme politique dit
ce n'est pas une technocrate qui a
transformé la sncf qui a été celle qui a
fait la réforme de la sncf qui a
transformé l'assurance chômage qui était
très attendu qui a remis la valeur
travail au coeur de la france alors que
c'est un sujet qui préoccupe tous nos
jeunes et les parents de nos jeunes pour
l'avenir de nos enfants et bien c'est
une femme politique qui met ses
expériences techniques au service du
pays un hôtel se soumettre à un vote de
confiance pour vous moi parce que salim
pas obligés à l'issue du discours
donnant aux moyennes à dire que c'est un
swing n'y appartient au président de la
république pour être clair je serai je
ne serai pas humble si je je prenais
position sur ce choix institutionnels en
tout cas ce qui est un peu stratégiques
à l'action vous savez mardi elle à elle
elle a réuni tous les ministres hier
elle était avec agnès panière une hache
et sur un déplacement sur le bouclier
tarifaire du gaz il faudrait aujourd'hui
elle est sur l'apprentissage et il
faudra aussi qu'elle affronte le
parlement eh bien elle elle s'y frottera
je pense que c'est pas un affrontement
d'abord c'est un dialogue et puis moi je
lui fais complètement confiance vous
savez je les ai vus à lidl est venue une
journée à lille pendant la campagne
présidentielle
effectivement c'est quelqu'un qui a
beaucoup de compétences techniques mais
pour moi c'est une force quand on veut
diriger le pays et donner une
direction à la france heureusement qu'on
a des femmes et des hommes extrêmement
compétents à leur tête et il ya des
réformes à faire notamment la retraite
le sujet qui préoccupe les français
retraite à 65 ans est ce que ça peut
faire partie des concessions des
concessions que la majorité va faire à
l'opposition une passe de l'opposition
ne veut pas entendre parler de la
retraite à 60 ans comme très difficile à
faire passer à priori est là elle a déjà
été très difficile puisqu'elle a été
abandonnée au dernier quinquennat parce
que elle elle crée effectivement au sein
de la société française des tensions qui
était bien trop forte alors qu'on était
dans la période de crise du coc vide etc
on n'a pas encore eu de discussions au
sein de notre groupe sur les thématiques
puisqu'on est en train de constituer
notre organisation autour de rouen
verger à l'assemblée nationale cela dit
moi j'ai entendu le président de la
république déjà au moment de l'élection
présidentielle
restez sur le principe d'une
progressivité du départ à la retraite
mais en évoquant des possibilités de
discussions avec les syndicats est
l'organe les organisations représentant
tous les métiers 65 64 on a
effectivement vous avez raison des
oppositions fortes sur ces sujets donc
ça s'est déjà dit qu'ils voulaient les
démocratique de discussion deux pas l'un
vers l'autre en tout cas nous on veut
préserver le système de santé par dans
le système de protection sociale dans
notre pays et le système de protection
de l'avenir de nos enfants avec une
réforme des retraites qui se tient nous
aurons des discussions un peu musclé sur
le sujet ça c'est clair allez on va
terminer cette émission avec le dernier
thème la présentation par les sénateurs
d'une proposition de loi pour encadrer
le recours au cabinet de conseil par
l'état un texte déposé trois mois après
les conclusions de leur commission d'
enquête qui avait jugé cette utilisation
je cite tentaculaire samia de sheer
leur commission d' enquête a révélé
l'ampleur du recours au cabinet de
conseil par l'état et ses opérateurs
plus d'un milliard d'euros en 2021 soit
deux fois plus qu'en 2018 les sénateurs
veulent tant cadre et le recours au
cabinet de conseil leur proposition de
loi transpartisane prévoit d'obliger le
gouvernement à publier chaque année la
liste de toutes les prestations de
conseil auquel il a recours depuis la
fin de nos travaux et de nos pouvoirs
banquette
personne ne connaît la liste de
prestations de conseil en cours ce qui
est nouveau est déjà un problème la
transparence repose désormais sur le
travail des journalistes qui saisissent
la commission d'accès aux documents
administratifs pour obtenir des
informations que l'administration refuse
souvent de leur donner plus de
transparence et de déontologie pour
éviter tout conflit d'intérêts le sénat
veut confier une mission de contrôle des
cabinets à la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique et pour
plus de traçabilité tout document
élaboré directement ou indirectement
avec un cabinet de conseil devra en
faire la mention ne souhaitons également
évité de confusion entre les cabinets de
conseil d'une part et les fonctionnaires
d'autre part un consultant n'est pas un
fonctionnaire il nous semble utile de le
rappeler au gouvernement à titre
d'exemple les cabinets de conseil ne
pourront plus ne pourront plus utiliser
le logo de l'administration pour rédiger
leur livrables les sénateurs proposent
aussi la destruction systématique des
données confiées au cabinet de conseil
sous le contrôle de la cnil les 16
signataires issus de tous bords
politiques ont écrit à elisabeth bornes
pour lui demander de lancer l' examen de
leur proposition de loi des s'était
brûlé au parlement
alors cette proposition de loi violette
spillebout talent et trans partisane à
elle va de l air aux communistes est ce
que vous vous auriez pu qu signer un tel
texte ah oui je pense que j'aurais pu
cautionner un tel texte je n'en suis pas
là mais si j'ai bien compris ça passera
en débat parlementaire à l'automne et je
m'en réjouis parce que c'est un sujet
anciens le recours au cabinet de conseil
depuis des années par la droite par la
gauche il ya eu un recours un peu c'est
une étape hier supérieur à ce qu'il y
avait avant pendant la crise parce qu'il
ya une mobilisation pour le plan de
relance pendant pour le plan de
résilience de d'action très urgente
autour des fonctionnaires à la même dans
les cintres et non de rabat ont été
commandés par exemple l'éducation aussi
j'ai parcouru on a on a vu aussi des
rapports d'évaluation sont des missions
qui avaient été payés qui n'étaient pas
avec de bons résultats ou une qualité
suffisante donc moi tout ce qui va dans
le sens de la transparence de la bonne
gestion de l'argent public du contrôle
et bien je pense que c'est ce qu'on doit
aux français aujourd'hui ils ont pas
envie qu'on jette lorrain vous allez va
être là dessus au contraire c'est un
sujet qui m'intéresse beaucoup parce que
dans les propositions qui a eu d'abord
il faut pas oublier qu'il ya eu en 2014
un rapport de la chambre régionale
chambre des comptes en 2014 ya déjà eu
des préconisations et c'est nous le
premier gouvernement autour d' emmanuel
macron en 2018 qui a commencé à m par
exemple une meilleure mise en
concurrence ou un meilleur contrôle
déontologique des dons qu'il était temps
de s'attaquer à ce sujet des gags c'est
lui qui est arrivé en libye
on va poursuivre là dessus et puis dans
les propositions par exemple prouvé que
on n'a pas dans les équipes les
fonctionnaires pour la compétence et qu'
il y a donc besoin d'un make our ça je
pense que c'est une bonne action prouver
que ce ne sont pas les cabinets de
conseil qui prennent des décisions mais
bien les ministères leur entourage et
puis aussi fort mais moi j'ai trouvé
intéressant dans les propositions forme
et finalement un cabinet de conseil
interne avec des hauts fonctionnaires
forme j'y croyais à intervenir et que
nous ayons notre personnel je pense que
ça va dans le bon sens même si je
n'oublie pas que toutes les
contributions ces cabinets de conseil
c'est d'abord 2000 entreprises en france
qui qui
emploie énormément de talent pour nous
aider à transformer et à rendre
notamment plus numérique et digital
notre pays notre fonction publique donc
voilà en tout cas vous voyez je vis je
serais si on me demande de travailler
sur ces sujets extrêmement volontaire et
puis à lille peut-être dernier sujet moi
j'ai vu beaucoup beaucoup place et aux
conseils municipaux et aux conseils de
lamelles des rapports de la chambre
régionale des comptes qui ensuite est
donc très bien fait et qui n'étaient pas
suivis après donc dans ma
circonscription les des sujets que je
porte ce qu'il veut je voudrais vous
poser une dernière question car le
parquet national financiers a ouvert une
enquête préliminaire pour blanchiment de
fraude fiscale aggravé qui vise le
cabinet mckinsey yankee un peu l'emblème
de toute cette commission denquête est
ce que les pouvoirs publics doivent
continuer à travailler avec ce cabinet
tant que rien n'est encore cette enquête
je pense qu'il ya une règle de prudence
la sueur sur cette enquête et ce cas
particulier après il faut bien rappeler
que le recours au cabinet de conseil
c'est des chiffres importants en
milliards millions d'euros mais c'est 0
3% de la masse salariale de l'état
français donc on est dans un sujet qu'il
faut régler je crois que les trois
commissions finalement la cour des
comptes la commission d'information de
l'assemblée nationale et maintenant la
commission transpartisane denquête au
sénat ont fait leur travail et
maintenant c'est à nous d'agir et d'être
très vigilants pour que rapidement tout
cela soit mieux encadré eh bien ce sera
le la fin merci beaucoup violette
spillebout d'or était notre invité et on
se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
une autre émission de parts le moins bon
ciao
[Musique]